the people of Florida just re-elected
him I'm assuming when they re-elected
him they were hoping he'd stay around
for a while so I mean he's I guess he's
in his 40s he's about 10 years younger
than me he's got a long political future
ahead of him and I think he should
respect that the people just voted him
in as governor and serve out that term
for the people of of Florida and then he
could obviously run for president but
this is President Trump's turn yeah so a
couple different things first of all I
had to look that up Ron DeSantis is 44
years old when I look at DeSantis I
don't see a guy who's five years older
than me I see a guy who looks 15 years
older than me he's genuinely 44 years
old that's stunning stuff I mean that's
an incredible incredible thing to
realize and I'm gonna have to process
that probably a little bit later because
it's bonkers